I get asked whether I should be a spy
spies are in the business of human
intelligence we are in the business of
understanding how and why
cryptocurrencies are used and what their
potential is and those are those are a
little bit different I'm Jonathan Levin
one of the cofounders of chain alysus
I'm 28 years old born in London now
living in New York gene alysus provides
anti money laundering
an investigation software for
cryptocurrencies essentially helping the
world's largest institutions tackle
money laundering and prevent bad people
from using cryptocurrencies we're
definitely a tech company we're mostly
engineers almost all today really trying
to make sure that we go deep on
understanding how and why
cryptocurrencies are used by people and
we don't provide financial services to
the market I didn't decide to go down
this road I thought I was gonna be a
consultant I thought I was gonna be an
environmental economist thinking about
carbon but then what happened was I
really found that the energy that you
get from being a consultant and tending
to clients that client doesn't give you
as much energy as you put into it and
and the entrepreneurial journey for me
was I needed something that when I put
my energy and effort into it it gives
back to me more than I put him the best
days into analysis or really those days
where the cases that our customers are
working on come too close these
investigations can be years in the
making and really we we make sure that
the whole company gets to celebrate the
wins of taking down the largest
child-abuse material sites in the world
those human stories are what motivate me
and also motivate people in the company
[Music]
you